the pandemic had many unanticipated side
effects on emissions on work travel and
more
so what was the environmental impact of
the pandemic our topic on this week's
covet 19 special
in indonesia for example illegal
deforestation increased
but first the coronavirus and animals do
animals and humans infect each other and
if so what can that teach us
scientists in the netherlands want to
find out
the province of flavorland in the heart
of the netherlands
dotted with fields of tulips canals and
modern architecture
but flavorland's capital leilestad isn't
just home to exotic concrete structures
it's also where the possible future
shape of the kovid 19 pandemic is being
sketched out
researchers at the vaganingnon
bio-veterinary research labs are looking
at the way sars kovi 2 behaves in animal
tissue now
and how it might behave in the years to
come
we need to study all kinds of animal
species that may be infected with
sarcoma virus too so first look whether
we see symptoms of source coronary virus
ii in these animals and if we see that
test these animals whether they're
infected and also whether they can
spread the virus
wim van der poel has studied the disease
for example in hamsters which can be
infected by covid19 and pass it on to us
symptoms in the rodents are not that
different than in humans they include
lethargy weight loss and shortness of
breath
this is what the lung tissue from a
hamster infected with covid19 looks like
by testing how viruses behave in animals
the scientists can anticipate and
estimate how great a threat they might
also pose to humans
the question of whether an animal is
able to spread covid19 is an important
one
the more virus cases there are whether
in animals or in humans the greater the
chances the virus will mutate
trying to reconstruct infection chains
is very complicated
one theory some scientists in china
proposed for the origins of the omicron
variant for example
is that the variant's predecessor could
have leapt from humans to mice a process
known as spillback they think it could
have mutated in the animals into
omicron's immediate ancestor which then
jumped back from mice to humans
and mice are not the only suspects
actually there are quite a number of
animal species that are susceptible
to the virus
the question is always whether
it is only an initial infection or
whether the animal will also be able to
transmit the virus to other species
or the same animal
mink do have the ability to transmit
kovid
this is what the coronavirus looks like
in them
after being first reported in the
netherlands in february 2020
covid19 ripped through mink populations
and european farms
when the virus mutated and the animals
began infecting staff at the farms
denmark's government took drastic action
and curled every farm mink in the
country millions of them
in denmark in the mink outbreak we saw
that the virus changed in a way that it
could be
could become more infectious to people
and could also spread more rapidly in
people so
these animal
transmissions can be very important and
can be very risky for public health
reasons
in the u.s researchers are now looking
at the potential threat posed by
white-tailed deer which may yet prove
problematic for the course of the
pandemic
the world health organization currently
estimates that one in three of the
animals across the whole of the u.s have
been infected with covid19
that's in the wake of an outbreak that
started mid-2021
one paper not yet peer-reviewed reports
a case where the viruses thought to have
jumped back from deer into humans
another danger is that deer could also
potentially spread the infection to
domesticated livestock
which would further increase the risk of
exposure and spread in humans
the wagon engine researchers are trying
to predict and possibly prevent events
like that before they can occur
it's a difficult task
well i hope that our modeling can help
us to bring us a step ahead of the of
the virus in the future because at the
moment
we
wait until a new variant arise and then
we respond to that
getting one step ahead would allow
vaccine developers time to test and
tweak vaccine alternatives
it could also provide early warnings to
public health officials to prepare
infrastructure a central aspect of
managing any pandemic
that the virus will change as a given
but being able to anticipate those
changes and prepare for them
could help save lives
illegal logging has long been a problem
in indonesia
but under the pandemic it's grown worse
in part because many communities turn to
logging to survive
[Music]
when kovite 19 hit indonesia the country
faced another outbreak deforestation
a report shows 50 more forests were
cleared in the first 20 weeks of 2020
than in the same period a year earlier
indonesian environmentalists like uli
arta sia geon say this spike in
deforestation was no coincidence
[Music]
when we talked with the authorities in
several regions they said that when they
were in lockdown during the pandemic
they weren't able to do their jobs as
usual
most of them were working at home
so the authorities said it was difficult
for them to monitor the forest
[Music]
says that forest patrols also fell
victim to budget cuts during the
pandemic
and the economic downturn had another
effect one that originated in the cities
as unemployment grew in urban areas
during lockdown many migrant workers
returned to their villages putting
further pressure on forests
the data showed that the migration of
people from cities to rural areas
increased significantly
from 36.7 million in 2019
it increased to 40 million people early
in the pandemic
these 40 million people are more than a
quarter of the total workers in
indonesia
people from the cities looked for work
in their villages where agriculture is
the dominant industry
but more people in the village means
less land to cultivate legally
the amount of land that can be legally
used has dropped when more people move
from cities to rural areas they try to
find new land
while much of the legal land in the
villages has been sold to large
companies for mining or large-scale
agriculture the villagers try to make a
living by illegally farming in the
forest
uh
in many cases they believed they had no
choice but to turn to illegal land in
the forest
many people were forced to find new land
in the forest to survive
but they can't be fully blamed the
problem is caused by agrarian inequality
which is the main cause of increased
deforestation in this
country in march 2020 indonesia lost
more than 1
200 square kilometers of forest
far more than in previous years
environmentalists are warning of a
looming catastrophe if deforestation
continues
during the pandemic coronavirus
restrictions kept many people at home
factory production was ramped down and
people commuted and traveled less what
impact did that have on greenhouse gas
emissions worldwide
our reporter spoke to miriam wolfram of
cdp europe an ngo that advises companies
cities and governments on how to build a
sustainable economy
hello mrs miriam wolfram very nice to
meet you we heard that the emissions
decreased during the height of the
pandemic and the lockdowns
can you tell us why
well first yes the emissions dropped
significantly during the pandemic around
eight percent according to the
international energy agency
and actually this is really the
emissions about the percentage of the
emissions um needed every year in
emissions cuts for the next decade so
until 2030 says the united nations to
meet our 1.5 paris target
and the reasons for these drops in
emissions julia is because many parts of
the world came to a first a forced still
stand in order to curb the spread of the
cobat virus bringing much of the global
economic activity to a halt
the inactivity affected mostly crown
transportation and aviation but also of
course industry and related power
generation causing carbon emissions to
decline
has this decrease had any significant
effect on climate change
no it has not is the unfortunate answer
also the pandemic and resulting
limitations on you know economic sectors
but also travel of course drastically
decreased air pollution and greenhouse
gas emissions at large
the decrease has no long-term impact the
only thing that will have long-term
impact is a systemic permanent change
so we have a momentum now and we must
ensure that we don't lose this momentum
that the pandemic might be also nearing
its end
and to give you one example cdp has
reported record disclosures between 2020
and 2022 an increase from 9600 companies
to over 13 000 companies reporting their
environmental data in 2022
the growth illustrates that the pandemic
has not stopped companies around the
globe to continue their efforts in you
know environmental transparency and
action and this is a good news it is
essential to maintain and strengthen
businesses now investors and governments
commitments as well as of course the
citizen support to really achieve and
continue moving into this just and
inclusive and green transition are the
emissions back to the same level as
before the pandemic now unfortunately
global emissions have rebounded to
quite varying levels in 2021 to reach
their highest ever annual level
with a six percent increase from 2020
according again to the international
energy agency
global energy review
this rebound has reversed the pandemic
included decline in emissions
and co2 emissions in 2021 rose above the
pre-pandemic levels in
2019.
coal for example accounted for over 40
percent of the oval growth
in global co2 emissions last year
and
deforestation land use and agricultural
expansion continue to contribute to
global emissions with agriculture
driving almost 90 percent of global
deforestation according to the u.n food
and agriculture organization
so in short the pandemic did not help
climate action thank you very much for
this interview
[Music]
the coronavirus makes people sick and so
do fine particulates
like the virus they enter the airways
and end up deep in the lungs
so is there a connection between fine
particulate pollution and covet 19. dw's
joachim eggers spoke with an expert on
fine particulates and their health
impact
brought something along miss peters this
is glitter let me quickly hold it up to
the camera
glitter so it's really small
is this the size of the particulate
matter we're talking about uh the fine
stuff
the fine particulate matter we're
talking about is a bit smaller
less than 2.5 micrometers
and this particulate matter is about a
millimeter if you inhaled it most of it
would get stuck in your nose and only a
few particles would end up deep in your
lung
the dangerous ones that go into your
lungs how big are they kind of
one millimeter is one thousand
micrometers this is um
a millimeter a thousand micrometer
well i brought this stuff along so that
we can demonstrate it so it's 100 times
smaller than this here
a thousand times smaller
100 to a thousand times smaller
that's amazing so you can't see it with
the naked eye
exactly you can't see it with the naked
eye
here we have up to 5000 particles per
cubic centimeter
and if you were to stand at a road with
a lot more traffic you'd get between
fifty thousand and one hundred thousand
particles per cubic centimeter
particular cubic centimeter
where does it come from
they're fine stop it define particulate
matter that can be dangerous to our
health is the result of combustion
processes it could be cars or power
plants coal power plants or domestic
heating all of these are sources for
particulate matter
drivers cyclists pedestrians and people
who live near busy streets with every
breath they inhale millions of
potentially dangerous tiny airborne
particles that affect their immune
systems
colleagues of mine at the barcelona
institute for global health carried out
a very good study
it showed that people who live in areas
with high air pollution levels have a 30
percent higher risk of developing
covid19 if they're infected
and her team are also conducting a
large-scale study
we have this
we now know that fine particulate matter
doesn't just affect the lungs but
basically the entire body
it can contribute to cardiovascular
disease to metabolic diseases and we
also know that fine particulate matter
affects the brain
well this
is whether that leads to higher rates of
covid19 in a particular region is one
question
the other question is what are the
long-term effects
does fine particulate matter also
contribute to long covid for example
peter's and her team's study involves
1500 subjects some of them have had
covert 19.
my husband and i had coveted last
november
my husband was in the hospital with
suspected pneumonia i was at home so we
were both in isolation
but you're both fine now
really we both still have trouble
walking we start to sweat when we exert
ourselves we can't handle it
the subjects undergo various tests
including a lung function test
many long-covered patients have trouble
getting enough air but the medical tests
are only part of the study
[Music]
i
the researchers also send out a car
that's especially equipped with a kind
of funnel on the roof they're measuring
the levels of fine particulate matter
where the materials live
we'll continue to collect data here in
the city of augsburg until the fall
then we'll carry out a quality control
process
in one to two years we'll have initial
results on fine particulate matter in
covid19 as well as on the various
infection control measures and people's
health during the pandemic
ivamektin is often touted as a wonder
drug for covid19 that's even though the
world health organization has said the
anti-parasitic is unproven as a
treatment
officials in mexico city have come under
fire after spending millions of euros
supplying ivamectin to residents with
covert 19.
for two years claudio cereso took
ivermectin thinking it would protect her
from getting coronavirus
the 53 year old had read about the
deworming agent's supposed benefits on
social media
but she knew the drug didn't work after
she and her husband contracted covert 19
earlier this year so when a doctor at a
public hospital gave them a medical kit
that contained ivermectin claudia was
skeptical
she says they weren't properly informed
and feels that their health was
experimented on
there was no information from the public
health authorities
neither on their home page nor from the
doctors
you feel like they're saying take it and
see what happens
she was one of 200 000 patients to
receive a medical kit distributed by
mexico city officials that contained
ivermectin
even though the who and the federal
government discouraged covert 19
treatment with the drug city authorities
carried out a survey that looked like a
clinical trial to justify its use
the document was published on the open
source platform sokariev
but in february the article was removed
for what sociology professor juan pablo
paldoguera calls its deliberately
misleading data
in addition to the statistical flaws
which were tremendous
the database was very poorly constructed
the analysis was biased
and the quasi-experimental methods
generated positive results
but they were forcing the data
city officials defended the distribution
of ivermectin citing its supposedly low
risk and cost at an early stage of the
pandemic when there was less evidence
and fewer available treatments however
officials declined to give an interview
to dw about the ethical questions of
supplying an unapproved drug without
providing information to patients
yet public health analyst javier tello
says city officials agreed to the
purchase of nearly 300 000 packages of
ivermectin worth an estimated 1.5
million dollars
they looked at the fact that large
quantities of the drug were bought
especially when the news of its possible
use first emerged
but that's a very bad justification from
the mexico city secretary of health
who said it was what they had based on
available evidence
but there was no evidence
mexico city has stopped distributing
ivermectin but the drug is still being
promoted by vaccine skeptics
misinformation that can cost lives
[Music]
during the pandemic many people around
the world took comfort in long-standing
traditions
celebrating festivals and reviving old
customs helps sustain families and
communities
so too in the mainly indigenous regions
of ecuador
every year in june the indigenous
communities of northern ecuador
celebrate intirami the sun festival
although in many parts of the country
this ancient ritual didn't take place
during the pandemic
blanca bonilla is a traditional healer
she works as a volunteer advisor to
local authorities in the kotakachi
region
when we heard there were covert cases in
the coastal area and also in other
countries
we had a clear plan about what we would
do once it reached our region
we made lots of positive progress with
our experiments fighting the virus
authorities and quechua villages work
hard to maintain a relationship of trust
the indigenous community's hierarchical
structures are respected and valued
and that didn't change during the
pandemic
we never thought it would hit us this
hard
our country and our communities
after the government ordered a lockdown
we had to take matters into our own
hands
but it wasn't all that hard
everyone here has their own garden
everyone stores produce
kotakachi canton has a population of
roughly 40 000 spread across urban and
rural parishes
the main industries are tourism and
agriculture
there were fewer covet infections here
than in other parts of ecuador
[Music]
in 2020 and 2021 the health office here
in kotakachi canton registered
1755 cases
30 patients died and 1715
patients recovered
[Music]
despite the restrictions in the last two
years
some remote rural communities chose to
celebrate the intirami festival of the
sun as usual
[Music]
when the pandemic went global it also
had an impact here in the countryside
it didn't only affect people's health
it affected celebrations and cultural
life here in the canton
is famous for its cultural life and
music there are many artists here it was
a blow for culture
for some communities in the andes and
ecuador the last two years had some
benefits they revived many of the
customs of their ancestors
many of our communities welcomed the
fact that young people began using
medicinal herbs again
for people who live in the countryside
all plants have medicinal value
our knowledge was handed down to us by
our mothers and grandmothers
by our elders by our neighbors
we're gradually acquiring more expertise
and sharing it with other communities
save our lives it was incredible
on june 24th and 25th the quechua
communities will celebrate in tirami and
the village squares will be filled with
life
that's all for this edition of our covet
19 special with a focus on the
environmental impact of the pandemic
next week we'll take stock of where
things stand in the pandemic right now
and check out some of the new research
on covid19 for now thanks for watching
and see you soon
[Music]
you